with a roll of the dice,
in a bride who'd been left at the alter.
But it turns out, this "new" human diagnosis
was neither new, nor was it uniquely human.
Veterinarians had been diagnosing, treating and even preventing
emotionally induced symptoms in animals
ranging from monkeys to flamingos, from to deer to rabbits,
since the 1970s.
How many human lives might have been saved
if this veterinary knowledge had been put into the hands
of E.R. docs and cardiologists?
Self-injury.
Some human patients harm themselves.
Some pluck out patches of hair,
others actually cut themselves.
Some animal patients also harm themselves.
There are birds that pluck out feathers.
There are stallions that repetitively bite their flanks until they bleed.
But veterinarians have very specific and very effective ways
of treating and even preventing self-injury
in their self-injuring animals.
Shouldn't this veterinary knowledge be put into the hands
of psychotherapists and parents and patients
struggling with self-injury?
Postpartum depression and postpartum psychosis.
Sometimes, soon after giving birth,
some women become depressed,
and sometimes they become seriously depressed and even psychotic.
They may neglect their newborn,
and in some extreme cases,
even harm the child.
Equine veterinarians also know that occasionally,
a mare, soon after giving birth,
will neglect the foal, refusing to nurse,
and in some instances, kick the foal, even to death.
But veterinarians have devised
an intervention to deal with this foal rejection syndrome
that involves increasing oxytocin in the mare.
Oxytocin is the bonding hormone,
and this leads to renewed interest,
on the part of the mare, in her foal.
Shouldn't this information
be put into the hands of ob/gyn's
and family doctors and patients
who are struggling with postpartum depression and psychosis?
Well, despite all of this promise,
unfortunately the gulf between our fields remains large.
To explain it, I'm afraid I'm going to have to air some dirty laundry.
Some physicians can be real snobs
about doctors who are not M.D.'s.
I'm talking about dentists and optometrists and psychologists,
but maybe especially animal doctors.
Of course, most physicians don't realize that it is harder
to get into vet school these days than medical school,
and that when we go to medical school,
we learn everything there is to know
about one species, Homo sapiens,
but veterinarians need to learn about health and disease
in mammals, amphibians, reptiles, fish and birds.
So I don't blame the vets for feeling annoyed
by my profession's condescension and ignorance.
But here's one from the vets:
What do you call a veterinarian
who can only take care of one species?
A physician. (Laughter)
Closing the gap has become a passion for me,
and I'm doing this through programs
like Darwin on Rounds at UCLA,
where we're bringing animal experts and evolutionary biologists
and embedding them on our medical teams
with our interns and our residents.
And through Zoobiquity conferences,
where we bring medical schools together with veterinary schools
for collabortive discussions
of the shared diseases and disorders
of animal and human patients.
At Zoobiquity conferences,
participants learn how treating breast cancer in a tiger
can help us better treat breast cancer
in a kindergarten teacher;
how understanding polycystic overies in a Holstein cow
can help us better take care
of a dance instructor with painful periods;
and how better understanding the treatment of separation anxiety
in a high-strung Sheltie
can help an anxious young child struggling with his first days of school.
In the United States and now internationally, at Zoobiquity conferences
physicians and veterinarians check their attitudes and their preconceptions
at the door and come together as colleagues,
as peers, as doctors.
After all, we humans are animals, too,
and it's time for us physicians to embrace
our patients' and our own animal natures
and join veterinarians
in a species-spanning approach to health.
Because it turns out,
some of the best and most humanistic medicine
is being practiced by doctors whose patients aren't human.
And one of the best ways we can take care
of the human patient is by paying close attention
to how all the other patients on the planet
live, grow, get sick and heal.
Thank you.
(Applause).